one of the areas where Donald Trump has
really bamboozled a lot of people when
it comes to his knowledge of an issue is
trade and economic policy this was
something that if you go back to the
2015 and 2016 Republican presidential
campaign Donald Trump very early on
started talking about China or China as
he likes to refer to it endlessly
talking about how the u.s. is losing the
trade deals are bad he understands that
he's going to fix it he's going to do
the negotiations like a businessman and
all of this stuff and because a lot of
other people he was talking to also
don't understand those issues he made a
lot of headway on the idea that he gets
it and he's going to fix it and even if
these supporters didn't fully understand
exactly what he was going to do or how
it was going to be good for them they
fell for it they were bamboozled and
then when Donald Trump became the
president of the United States he
tricked his supporters into thinking
that the things he was doing were good
right the trade policy the trade war
with China the tax policy which a lot of
the benefit was from changing the
withholdings tables and people thought
they were having more money than they
file their taxes and they actually paid
more in tax for the year in total and
all of it seemed to make sense to them
oh yeah Trump's doing great it's all
good for us
but the truth is that that was not at
all the case and I want to take some
time today to look at the news of Donald
Trump bragging about and his supporters
bragging about signing the us-china
phase one trade deal what the hell does
phase-1 mean what are they talking about
what is this all about so the day before
yesterday Donald Trump and China's vice
premier Liu hae signed the us-china
phase one trade deal in terms of tariffs
this means very little but we'll talk
about what it does do and what it
doesn't do most importantly what it does
not do signing this phase one trade deal
does not end the trade war Donald Trump
has not lowered tariffs on Chinese goods
top line that's the most important thing
to understand everything else is more or
less secondary to that really this was a
photo op for Donald Trump here is a
little video Trump making
a huge deal out of all of this were
showing video of the signing ceremony
that the Trump White House dreamed up
you know how they like to do it with a
whole bunch of people Donald from
signing a bunch of copies taking forever
to just write his name it's all very
weird but the important thing is what
does the deal do one of the things
that's in this phase one deal is that it
commits China to cracking down on the
theft of American technology and
corporate secrets it's not nothing okay
but in the context of the failed trade
war that Donald Trump is waging it's
pretty underwhelming the deal includes a
two hundred billion dollar spending
package by China to close a little bit
of the trade imbalance with the United
States now I want to get back to that
because we have that trade imbalance for
a reason Donald Trump objectively cites
it as a as a deficit by deficit I mean
he decides it as a negative thing but
our economy is actually based on that
and we'll talk about that later
phase one deal that was signed commits
China to avoiding currency manipulation
to gain an advantage and it has a system
for enforcing that of course then you've
got a debate whether the currency was
manipulated to gain an advantage or not
and then you're in five years of arguing
about that the really important thing is
what's missing from this deal this deal
does nothing to address Chinese hacking
of American companies that's something
that supposedly they were going to be
talking about and dealing with it does
nothing about that the deal does nothing
about the subsidies from the Chinese
state that have fueled Chinese companies
around the world arguably to the
detriment of American companies now I'm
not taking a position here on that
that's a debate in and of itself about
what makes sense and what doesn't make
sense
protectionism America economic
nationalism etc but they said this was
one of the things they wanted to deal
with and they are not dealing with it in
phase one of this deal it also does not
end the trade war it does not remove the
disastrous tariffs now of course the
Trump administration says all of that is
going to come in phase two so really the
headline here is something has been
passed Donald Trump can claim it as a
win people who don't know much
believe that it's a win and maybe when
you go interview Trump supporters at
rallies and say what is Trump accomplish
that you like they'll say well he did
the phase one trade deal even if in
reality it doesn't do very much now to
be charitable if I wanted to be as
charitable as possible about this phase
one deal I could say signing something
anything as long as it has even a tiny
step forward it could generate momentum
for doing something bigger okay I mean
that's the most charitable analysis and
time will tell whether it's a good
analysis whether it actually leads to
anything further but again it's just an
opportunity for Trump to brag and here
he is doing it the agreement tears down
major market barriers for us food and
agricultural exports China will now
welcome American beef and pork poultry
seafood rice dairy infant formula animal
feed biotechnology and much much more so
you get the idea now let me talk a
little bit about the trade imbalance
this is really important to understand
and I I've mentioned it in passing
before Donald Trump constantly talks
about the trade deficit we're importing
way more from China than we are
exporting to China and we've got to fix
this you don't just fix that because our
economy for decades has been based on
that decades ago when outsourcing of
labor started to go elsewhere
when outsourcing of manufacturing
started to go elsewhere and we
increasingly became a service based
economy when you do that you were
essentially deciding we are going to
prioritize cheap stuff from overseas to
fuel our economy rather than higher
wages and more expensive stuff that's
produced locally so a different example
this is not a perfect example but a lot
of people when they go to Switzerland or
they hear about Switzerland they go and
they have sticker shock a cheeseburger
is 28 Swiss francs I remember it like it
was yesterday when I was in Zurich a
couple years ago I said this must be the
best cheeseburger around now it was just
a normal cheeseburger it's extremely
expensive for
everything but you have people who were
working what in the US would not be
well-paid jobs earning a living wage and
it's a different type of economy and
things cost more but there's a higher
standard of living
you have taxes used to fund a number of
social services okay that's one way a
company a a country's economy can go in
the United States the decision was made
and it doesn't have to be an explicit
decision where everybody says we don't
care about wages we want to keep prices
down for people and we're gonna do it
with cheap stuff from China that is what
the economy is based on so the idea that
Donald Trump is going to just fix the
trade imbalance without realizing that
he has to completely restructure the
economy and undo decades of the economy
being organized in this way to call it
naive would be a huge understatement
remember that whenever we talk about the
trade deficit with China more
smoke-and-mirrors more lack of any real
understanding of economics or trade but
it's all politics it's something that
Trump supporters if they remember it can
say Trump accomplished in order to
justify voting for him instead of
whoever is the Democratic nominee in
November which is ultimately what they
want to do I know that the David Pakman
show audience is full of curious and
creative people who love learning new
things and bettering themselves and
that's why I'm so excited to tell you
about one of our sponsors Skillshare the
vibrant online learning community that
offers thousands of classes on almost
any topic you can imagine and you'll get
full access to the entire library of
classes for two entire months free when
you go to david pakman.com slash skill
all of the classes are taught by experts
in their fields they've got classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design bookkeeping marketing
personal productivity doesn't even
scratch the surface I recently took a
class about photography if anybody
follows me on instagram you know that my
photography skills leave much to be
desired and it was great I got so much
out of it and hopefully you will see the
fruits of me taking that class reflected
in my Instagram pictures sooner than
later they have classes for every skill
level whether you're wanting to get
better at some
thing you already have experienced with
you want to learn something totally new
to you you set your own pace classes are
usually less than an hour long they're
divided up into bite-size segments so
you can easily fit them into your
schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in creativity
Skillshare really makes it easier than
ever
Skillshare memberships are less than 10
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll